dad is trying to distance himself from
an apparently cozy and suspicious
relationship with Russia it's probably
not a good idea to hang out with someone
who is rumored to be Vladimir Putin's
girlfriend when your dad's campaign
manager Paul manna forts name appears on
a handwritten ledger as being entitled
to somewhere between 12 and 13 million
dollars in possibly illegal payments
from pro-russian groups you may not want
to be spotted arm in arm with Vladimir
Putin suppose a girlfriend but that's
exactly what Donald Trump's daughter
Ivanka Trump whose body Donald Trump is
absolutely stunned by as we've covered
before just as the best body and if it
wasn't his own daughter Trump would love
to date her uh Ivanka Trump was in a
picture which I will show you here with
Wendy dang Murdoch in Croatia seemingly
having a grand old time and you'll
notice that last name Murdoch Wendi Deng
Murdoch that is not a coincidence that
is because she is the ex-wife of Fox
News Overlord in chief Rupert Murdoch
for years rumors have swirled that
Murdoch's ex-wife and Trump's up buddy
Vladimir Putin maybe buddy is a bit much
so possible future buddy Vladimir Putin
were dating and the Kremlin has not
denied that relationship dang did
flat-out deny the accusations at one
point but now anonymous sources within
the Kremlin are saying oh no no this is
a serious relationship it seems to me it
would have been wise for Ivanka Trump to
avoid even the even the appearance of a
possible relationship here because she's
very involved in her dad's campaign
increasingly we see any number of
compelling connections between Donald
Trump's campaign and Paul Manafort and
Russia and Vladimir Putin and Viktor
Yanukovych etcetera etcetera and now it
turns out that they're vacationing
together it certainly doesn't look good
better yeah bad optics uh of all I'll
say this could just be the whole
worldwide billionaires club type thing
uh they're all friends they're all
buddies they all know each other but
certainly bad optics and this you should
know better
if you're
if you're the daughter of the Republican
nominee yeah I should know better and
Jason you've worked on movies that have
scripts if the 2016 narrative was
written into a Hollywood script I can
only assume producers would say this is
so far-fetched and unbelievable that
it's not worth producing this film
because it's just so clearly
over-the-top and it's actually what
could end up in history books I mean
nope no Hollywood producer would would
believe this because it's so insane I
mean it could be a really good sci-fi
flick it could be Trump gets elected and
now it's the you know United States of
Russia and America coming to you
we need a flow chart actually to show
the connections between Trump Rupert
Murdoch Paul Manafort Vladimir Putin
Viktor Yanukovych Wendy dang Murdoch
Ivanka Trump and probably Roger Ailes it
is somewhere in this flow chart don't
you think and we might as well include
gretchen carlson and megyn kelly while
we're at it
Oh megyn kelly absolutely I mean she
heard drop uh and by the way Hillary
Clinton boot could probably be on there
she was at Donald Trump's wedding Trump
has donated to Hillary Clinton this this
election would probably require the most
convoluted and extensive flow chart to
figure out as Trump likes to say what
the hell is going on
yeah it's and we could call it an
incestuous election uh couldn't we well
do it that would be a huge
understatement
yeah that's what it is so there it is
Ivanka clearly having a grand old time
with Vladimir Putin's reportedly serious
girlfriend and palm Anna for twelve
thirteen million bucks from pro-russian
groups no connection whatsoever of
course between the Trump campaign and
Vladimir Putin am I missing some element
of this is my flowchart missing a few
names let me know on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and of course our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home Tryon to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the David
Pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com slash TDP s it costs nothing